This is Dr. Tom Biernacki
Tom Biernacki, and these are the top
five drinks to decrease your gout
and uric acid levels.
Naturally.
And we're starting now.
Do you have a painful
big toe or big toe joint
pain in the morning when you wake up
and it's throbbing and it's aching?
It can happen to your fingers, your feet.
Most commonly
this could be hyperthermia and gout.
This is severe pain where you can
barely put your feet on the ground.
It's so common.
I see it all the time.
So what is hyper yersinia?
Hyperglycemia is a condition
that leads to go.
These are closely related conditions
and are often
addressed by podiatrists
such as myself and a rheumatologist.
We usually take a look at the uric acid
level in your blood.
Hyper yersinia is a medical condition
characterized
by high levels of something
called the uric acid in the blood.
Uric acid is a waste product
that's formed by the breakdown of purines.
So purines are a DNA product.
So essentially, as you eat meat,
as you eat seafood,
these have DNA in them.
And this essentially causes you
to create more uric acid.
But here's really the trick.
People who are on carnivore diets
that are lean
and are healthy,
they're usually not the people getting go.
But when you have high fructose
corn sirup, lots of sugar, you're obese.
You're dehydrated.
You're drinking alcohol.
You're drinking beer, wine.
You're not getting enough water.
This summer, heat's on you.
Your kidneys are overworked.
Your body can't get rid of that uric acid.
So essentially, it's managing
how much uric acid
your body's producing versus
how much you're getting out.
So if you're
hardly getting any help and building up,
it will build up in your body.
So this is why people say that meat
and seafood causes it.
But the reality is
if everything's working correctly,
you can get that uric acid out of here.
And that's why it's tricky.
The causes of hyper yersinia
are the increased production of uric acid.
10% of people do have genetic issues
where they can't
digest it properly
and it builds up in excessive levels.
So I've had some patients that are young,
they're thin,
they don't do any of this bad stuff
that we're going to talk about.
That's a different story.
You might need some medications
to help you put that uric acid.
But the vast majority of people,
I'm talking like 95% that are watching
this video.
It is something that you could correct
very easily over time.
So there's a lot of hope
with this disorder.
Things that contribute to your acid
build up are Hyperion diets.
So if you're eating just excessive amounts
of seafood and meat,
if you're obese, if you're also taking
in high fructose corn
sirup,
that creates a lot of abdominal fat.
Certain medications can do it.
Some medical conditions can do it
and genetics can do it.
What are the risk factors?
While not a disease
itself, hyper Yersinia can lead to go
and other health issues
such as kidney stones and renal failure.
So high uric acid levels essentially it's
kind of like putting too much sugar
in a glass of water.
Eventually it deposits at the bottom.
And that's why the big toe is
the first joint to fill up with uric acid.
And it's almost like crystals
in the joint.
That's why it hurts so much. That's gout.
Gout is a form of inflammatory arthritis
caused by the deposition of monosodium
crystals.
So uric acid turns into monosodium
urate crystals
causing hyper a severe it's severe pain
with swelling redness in the joint,
especially the big toe joint.
And what we want to do is we want to drink
those fluids and clean out that joint.
If you think you had this,
come see a podiatrist like myself,
especially if you're in the Michigan area,
we can essentially drain that joint.
See if there's crystals in it.
You could do blood tests to check for uric
acid levels and joint fluid analysis.
You could do an X-ray
to check an ultrasound
to see if there's crystal in there.
And we take a look at your diet,
your lifestyle and family history.
And there's a lot of great new treatments,
a lot of great
new solutions coming out,
including long term management.
Here's the top five drinks.
Number one, the green tea.
Green tea is a potent
ally against high uric acid levels.
Number one, the tea hydrates you.
So drinking a lot of fluid that can help
cycle out the blood
and clean up that uric acid.
So you want to avoid dehydration,
you want to keep drinking.
But green tea has antioxidants
that actively reduce uric acid levels,
and they combat inflammation
associated with conditions like gout.
Now, the trick here is
you want to limit your inflammation.
So anything you can do to lower
inflammation
and regular consumption
of green tea promotes overall health,
including improved cardiovascular
health and metabolism.
While this is helpful, it's
not the only thing you want to get fit.
You want to hydrate.
You want to switch to healthy liquids.
On a molecular level, Green tea actually
does have compounds that inhibit zam
thien function
and inhibit uric acid production.
So this is something well-studied
at this point.
Number two, low fat or skim milk
is a creamy hero in lowering uric acid
levels.
Low fat or skim
milk is rich in proteins and low in fats.
Effectively, this can reduce uric acid
content in the bloodstream.
Incorporating low fat or skim
milk into daily routines promotes
bone health and potentially reduces
the risk of gout associated complications.
It serves as a comforting
and nutritious addition to your beverages
and allows for natural management
of uric acid levels.
In the past, we used to eat sucrose, which
could be used in your blood immediately.
But then high fructose corn sirup
or HFCs was introduced
because corn was subsidized.
The problem is corn
is made up of fructose,
and fructose has to be turned to fat
and to sugar storage.
It can't be utilized
directly in our blood.
The real benefit of milk here
is that there's no fructose in milk.
It is something called the lactose.
And while some people can't tolerate
lactose well.
When we looked at goat production,
your acid production
100 years ago,
dairy levels were pretty consistent.
And essentially gout
did not exist at this time.
But as we added other drinks with added
sugars, added fats,
more white grains or white flowers,
that's when it took off.
So I think in the studies
and the recommendations, the rationale is
that milk does not contain fructose.
Considered a healthier option
than alternatives.
And it won't create guilt per say.
But you shouldn't focus on drinking a
ton of milk while you have and go to tech.
Number three, lemon water.
This is a zestful choice in managing
gout and high uric acid levels.
The vitamin
C in lemon water can neutralize uric acid.
This can prevent crystallization and
the formation of gout in kidney stones.
Incorporating lemon water into daily
routines offers a simple and effective way
to maintain a healthy balance
of uric acid in the body.
Extending the use of citrus fruits
in vitamin C complements how effective
the lemon water is in managing
uric acid levels naturally.
Number four, herbal tea, herbal teas.
Holistic approach to addressing
uric acid related concerns.
Herbal teas like camomile,
lavender, green tea, hibiscus tea offer
unique properties in managing gout
symptoms and high uric acid levels.
Sipping on herbal teas not only hydrates,
but also provides a anti-inflammatory,
calming, antioxidant and diuretic effects
to help you pee more that pee
and cycling of your kidneys
will help soon that uric acid level.
Number five Coffee.
Coffee has an unexpected role
in managing high uric acid levels.
The beauty is, even though coffee does
dehydrate you, it can help you out more.
So you want to be drinking water
plus drinking coffee
and it can help you cycle
that fluid out of there and get more uric
acid out of their coffee,
especially when made with skimmed
or low fat milk may have protective
effects against guilt symptoms
contributing to uric acid control,
moderate coffee consumption.
We're talking like two cups
a day, adds a flavorful dimension
and can help control high
uric acid levels.
Enjoying coffee as part of a balanced diet
offers an unexpected
but permissible indulgence
and helps you with uric acid balance.
The thing is,
these are long term strategies.
The coffee can help
cycle it out of there and the caffeine
can help with some pain levels.
What you want to do
is if you're having pain immediately,
check out my immediate home remedy guides
that you can use immediately the
morning you wake up.